nicolas gandrille de la rédaction de tv
78 nous a rejoint en plateau bonjour
bonsoir marylène alors avec vous nous
allons parler entrepreneuriat avec un
nouveau record plus de 750 mille
entreprises ont été créées en france en
2019 une augmentation de plus de 16% sur
un an
nicolas retrouve le même phénomène dans
le département dans la région une
tendance similaire même plus forte que
au niveau national regarder cette
infographie sur l'évolution des
créations d'entreprises sur ces dix
dernières années à partir de 2015 la
courbe des créations d'entreprise en ile
de france s'envole elle passe au dessus
de celle au niveau national une
augmentation plus importante qu au
niveau national
maintenant si on prend au niveau des
yvelines l'évolution est similaire les
chiffres de l'insee montre que en 2019
plus de 18000 500 sociétés ont été
créées soit une hausse de 9,2 pour cent
par rapport à 2018
et si on compare 2018 à 2017 les
créations d'entreprises se sont
fortement accrues à hauteur de 19,81 7%
alors comment peut-on expliquer le
succès des créations d'entreprises est
bien marienne plusieurs facteurs un
justifie cette augmentation depuis ces
dernières années
tout d'abord la simplification des
procédures pour créer son entreprise
c'est plus facile de créer son
entreprise
on est accompagné aussi plus fortement
qu auparavant avec des structures comme
le ski cube sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
il ya aussi des aides financières qui
sont proposées par l'état et les
collectivités aux entrepreneurs les taux
d'intérêt bas aussi favorisent l'accès
au crédit pour lancer un projet
d'affaires
enfin il ya une évolution aussi dans la
société de nombreux salariés ne veulent
plus du salariat ils veulent se lancer
dans l'entreprenariat et
l'entrepreneuriat c'est aussi une
solution pour les demandeurs d'emploi et
donc réduire le chômage
ce phénomène est il a nuancé peut-être
effectivement marylène c'est positif
les créations d'entreprises permettent
de booster l'économie mais
l'entrepreneuriat c'est une aventure
c'est des risques pris par les créateurs
d'entreprise avec parfois des
défaillances pour les activités lancées
c'est à dire que toutes les créations
d'entreprises ne sont pas forcément des
success stories comme on dit dans
l'économie et quand le projet fonctionne
se construit il n'y a pas forcément des
revenus immédiats
le créateur d'entreprise peut avoir des
difficultés au début à se payer soi même
et donc un chiffre qui permet de montrer
cela le revenu moyen des micro
entrepreneurs actifs n'étaient que 2 470
euros par mois
2017 selon les chiffres de l'insee merci
nicolas landry